elle est formidable cette phrase de jean
marie le pen on ne contrôle pas c'est
exactement ce que lui reprochent sa
fille aujourd'hui d'une certaine manière
on ne le contrôle pas et ne peut pas le
contrôler et voilà qui boucle la boucle
presque trente ans après qui ouvre donc
notre débat tel père telle fille ou pas
en quoi marine le pen est elle
l'héritière de jean-marie le pen
en quoi est elle différente voulait-il
vraiment le pouvoir d'une question qui
est beaucoup revenue sur le tapis ou
seulement être un agitateur un
provocateur une sorte de or system et
puis que peut-être le front national
sans jean marie le pen
on va en parler avec pierre jouve le co
réalisateur de ce film avec ali magoudi
les dits et les non dits de l'open c'est
un livre que vous avez publié la
découverte je le signale le député
européen du front national bruno
gollnisch qui fut notamment le directeur
de campagne de jean marie le pen en 2002
l'un des derniers fidèles aussi du père
contre la fille cécile alduy professeur
de littérature à l'université de
stanford de l'observatoire des
radicalités également co-auteur de
marine le pen prise au mot on verra si
le discours a changé au en profondeur au
front national chez les marinistes en
tout cas et puis dominique albertini de
libération co auteur d'une histoire du
front national édité chez taillandier
pierre jouve d'abord ce film pourquoi il
n'a jamais été diffusé trente ans
presque 1 d'abord parce que je pense que
tf1 l'époque de mougeotte michèle cotta
hésité à diffuser quelque chose qui bien
que critique de jean marie le pen le
montrer au fond séduisant ce qu'il
pouvait séduire ou voulait séduit
craignait de faire de la publicité
journal oui il ya un côté double comme
sonné en 88 il ya un côté 12 ans le père
quand il contourne la loi par exemple
sur les
sur par exemple sion parle de racisme
jamais raciste directement mais parle
indirectement par des allusions
également vous le trouver sympathique
fermement
enfin moi je me sens qu'il entonne les
chansons de cowboys par exemple de
sauter d'un film sur jacques chirac je
m'étais profondément ennuyé et nous
avions ce numéro de ce numéro
jean marie le pen qui essayait est
arrivé à restructurer ce qui est l
extrême droite a transgressé le tabou à
et aussi à rétablir un électorat
d'extrême droite ou de droite
alors ma remarque était que en sortant
de ce chirac je vais le noter que en
tournant avec chirac en france comme
j'ai tourné avec le pen je voyais bien
qu'il y avait 30 % des gens de chez
chirac quand même un peu plus ce qu'ils
étaient un peu interchangeables comme ça
donc il pouvait glisser dans le camp
hollande a joué lors des lycées qui
avait la même idéologie ce n'était pas
très loin s'arrêter fortement d'être
vigilent
ils jouent le jeu jean marie le pen
parce que vous lui voue le psychanalyse
et ils n'aiment pas ça non
les jouent le jeu et elle n'a pas peur
aucun de ceux qui sont à ce niveau n'a
peur de l'entrée dans un plateau dans
des interviews de ben spies mais ils
jouent complètement le jeu et joue dix
fois plus le jeu que jacques chirac joue
pas autant jeu que mitterrand qui était
extrêmement dans le film que nous avions
fait extrêmement est allé extrêmement
loin sur
dans l'introspection sa définition sa
définition
quel est le moment le plus révélateur de
films sur la personnalité de jean-marie
le pen pour vous il n'y a pas de moment
il ya une espèce de noeud découverte au
fond si le moment le plus important
c'est lorsqu'ils passent d'un homme
extrêmement civilisé normes extrêmement
raffinée et cultivée par rapport au
personnel politique il faut quand même
le dire il a un vocabulaire référence
dans une histoire très forte
et soudain ça se crispe et ça ce christ
sur ce qui le travaille à l'âme depuis
toujours c'est-à-dire la l'insécurité on
va en parler après la perte du
territoire tout ce qu'il a vécu
lorsqu'il était enfant
ça vient de l'enfance et moi en
particulier qui se substituent quand
même très fortement à la patrie on en
entendra j'espère on en parlera bruno
gollnisch vous partager la vision de
jean marie le pen en tout cas que
l'huître entrant transporte dans cl oui
mais je ne partage pas les commentaires
de monsieur j'ouvre bien que je trouve
qu'il ya des choses intéressantes
documentaire je trouve qu'un certain
nombre de commentaires relèvent d'un
petit peu d'une psychanalyse facile mais
en réalité ce qui est vrai c'est que
nous sommes tous tributaires de notre
expérience et c'est vrai que jean marie
le pen a connu sept 7 épreuves de la
guerre avec cette épreuve de la mort de
son père alors qu'il était mineur qui
était de l'effondrement d'un univers
parce que c'est le veuvage de sa mère
parce que c'est là la perte de toutes
les ressources morales le matériel c'est
un drame épouvantable à l'innovation un
journalise et oui monsieur je ne suis
pas d'accord avec ce qui est dit sur
l'humiliation
mais ce qui est c'est vrai que c'était
un enfant de famille modeste bien sûr et
qu'il a pu rencontrer une certaine
arrogance dans une certaine bourgeoisie
c'est possible mais ce n'est pas ça qui
le détermine en revanche je crois que
ceux qui le déterminent c'est vrai
il me l'a dit d'ailleurs encore
récemment c'est le fait que orphelins de
guerre
il était pupille de la nation et il y
avait une formule officielle d'ailleurs
à cela la nation adopte le mineur genre
le pen
et là c'est vrai que il m'a dit je me
suis sentie adoptée par la france en
quelque sorte
et par conséquent il en est résulté je
pense une grande partie de son
patriotisme et son refus du déclin mais
c'est vrai que les gens qui ont vécu
l'effondrement de l'armée française en
1940 il on nous en ont reçu un très
grand choc et ils ont perçu là quel
point cette cette france qui rayonnait
sur les cinq continents étaient quand
même une réalité fragile et je que je
voudrais dire c'est quand même que dans
ce domaine le pen a été prémonitoire
c'est ce que montre votre film il a
était prémonitoire le communisme gardons
nous de tout anachronisme le
documentaire date d'il ya presque trente
ans 88 à l'époque le communisme c'était
une menace et le communisme a conquis
par les armes l'indochine et il y fait
toujours régné son son régime
dictatorial le pen avait raison le
déclin démographique l'immigration
l'insécurité vous dit qu'il a peur il a
peur et c'est pas c'est pas un homme
craintif le pen mais c'est vrai que il
ressent le fait que nous ne sommes pas
dans un monde de bisounours et qu'il y a
et qu'il y à un certain nombre de péril
il peut être pire il perçoit caterham il
est monté dans le film il joue de la pro
a et l'a réveillé les français ou les
gens viennent et la pose la question du
progrès le tabou s qui joue de la
provocation
est ce que c'est un joueur je crois que
c'est un homme libre qui a une profonde
détestation du prêt-à-penser de les
bousculer les journalistes d'ailleurs
courageux ont appelé le
la dictature de la pensée et il défie le
système parce qu'ils considèrent que le
système conduit la france à sa perte et
je crois que les événements ne lui donne
pas tort enfin en tout cas c'est mon
analyse
voilà mais il est faux de dire que par
exemple il n'a jamais voulu le pouvoir
il faut dire qu'il a écoulé
classiquement combattu parce que à
l'époque où monsieur j'ouvre je sais pas
si monsieur jour me démentira mais à
l'époque où monsieur chouf dans le
commentaire et comme hostile lui
permettra de le lui dire tourner ce film
par exemple pratiquement je m'en
souviens toutes les réunions publiques
que nous faisons ou moins une réunion
publique sur deux au moins à l'échelon
local et physiquement agressé il faut il
faut se souvenir
il faut se souvenir de ce qu'ont été les
persécutions à l'encontre du front
national monsieur jourdain moment par
exemple parle de présente le pen comme
étant un homme obsédé par l'idée de
complot il n'est pas obsédé mais c'est
vrai quand même qu'il ya une conjonction
des forces contre le front national
c'est vrai que là la première ou la
seule réforme du gouvernement chirac
par exemple c'est de modifier le mode de
scrutin pour faire disparaître la
trentaine de députés à la région
rappelle que la proportionnelle avaient
permis l'entrée dont vous d'ailleurs et
la mère de députés à l'assemblée
nationale peut parler de beaucoup de
choses
vous vous revendiquez l'idée d'art fait
un documentaire de parti-pris engagé à
charge
non non non vous commentaires sont pas
fameux il va vous répondre parce que
pour les cous été l'objet vous êtes
acteur donc à la fois juge et partie
moi je suis que je peux dire mais
à juges condamnent et je voudrais dire
deux mots avaient pour la suite de
l'émission c'est quand même jean marie
le pen est le petit-fils de grands
parents qui ne savaient pas le français
qui parlait que le breton
son père et sa mère ont été les premiers
qui ont parlé le français et l'ont
appris grâce à l'état sont super le
confortent dans une dans une sévérité le
force à être élève il c'est la france
qui donnent une bourse et la france
l'état français qui donne une bourse à
jean marie le pen et ceci va donner à le
pen une image de la france qui sort la
famille le pen tout même de l'ornière
ensuite le père meurt à peu près au
moment où la france est envahie et c'est
donc deux instabilité qui se se
conjuguent
c'est quelque chose qui qui va être
permanent dans la vie de le pen que l'on
voit réapparaître tout au longde des
interviews est quelque chose qu'il va
communiquer aux gens qui sont dans
l'insécurité dans les meetings plus le
vent souffle dans le mauvais sens
économiquement plus il ya du monde et
puis il ya des gens qui n'y ont de moins
en moins confiance dans la patrie dans
l'état ça vaut pour sa fille aujourd'hui
ça vaut pour le réaliser c'est
l'actualité du jour et c'est ce qui est
raconté dans le film
et en ce qui concerne l' humiliation je
ne suis pas d'accord lorsqu'il était
boursiers il m'a raconté
c'est peut-être pas dans le film et vous
êtes boursiers mais le pen allait donc
au fond de la classe c'est elle
niveau des professeurs comme et ensuite
au il raconte dans le film que la voir
on observait les culottes
les femmes qui étaient au lavoir
s'observait légumes et autres il le dit
dans le film de qualité
il parle de lui c'est quand même un
facteur d'explication qui paie manqué
permanent chinois
alors continuons si vous voulez avec a
démontré de avec un extrait de ce film
une famille stable
c'est une chose qui est claire chez jean
marie le pen c'est qu'il n'a pas peur
des mots on écoute ça existe
je vais vous il y à des noirs il ya des
jaunes il y à la race kabila à sarralbe
enfin bref ça existe oui croyez pas
alors je crois que cette espèce de
d'inhibition sémantique qui consiste à
considérer ce mot c'est confondre le
racisme hélas c'est il me semble oui non
ne croyez pas vous ne croyez pas qu'ils
aient une race juive
je crois que c'est évident bah oui ça me
paraît évident qui d'ailleurs protège
quoi ces caractéristiques et sa son
identité et sa pureté par l'application
de règles extrêmement strictes
extrêmement stricte je crois
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui lui a permis de
maintenir son identité ses traditions et
sa particularité
depuis quatre millénaires cécile alduy
ça a disparu ça du discours de marine le
pen
oui complètement cette manière de briser
les tabous linguistique justement sur un
certain nombre de mots comme le mot race
qui en france est complètement tabou ça
ça a disparu
mais ce que je voudrais juste souligner
c'est à quel point ce qu'on vient
d'écouter et totalement communs chez
jean marie le pen se dire que dans ses
livres aussi il a des chapitres sur bien
sûr la race est une évidence presque
scientifique pour lui et que il manie à
la fois une sorte de rhétorique de
l'évidence c'est une évidence c'est
quelque chose qui n'est même pas à
discuter et en même temps un flou
artistique
quand il part de la race juive entre
guillemets en dix ans elle a su
préserver sa pureté entre guillemets ses
caractéristiques sa particularité est là
il faut quand même faire un décryptage
il ya ben c'est pas que les risées c'est
quoi c'est une particularité biologique
ça veut dire que derrière ça c'est pas
simplement une communauté culturelle ou
religieuse mais vraiment la définition
raciale la plus biologique qu'il soit et
donc cette connotation raciale a disparu
du langage officiel du front national
encore de 2016 parce que il y à l'état
major
il ya les représentants du front
national est appuyé après les militants
il ya les gens qui soutiennent le front
national par exemple on a fait des
analyses statistiques des tweets des
gens qui supportent qui soutiennent
pardon le hashtag marie le pen officiel
et c'est pendant les élections
départementales c'est paris match qu'a
fait cette étude et c'était très
emblématique de voir qu'il y avait du
point de vue des représentants du parti
dont des élus des candidats un discours
orienté sur l'économie sur l'europe sur
le département la politique et du côté
des militants des mots acheta qu'ils
sont français de souche les les muses
les
musulmans etc et un vocabulaire raciste
qui était beaucoup plus limpide je
chasse marine le pen aujourd'hui de son
parti il ya la commission des conflits à
laquelle vous apparteniez bruno
gollnisch je crois vous en avez été
exfiltré jeudi le mou comme ça
pudiquement tout quand vous annoncez
vous n'en faisait plus partie elle
chassait ça c'est la nouvelle politique
du front national
rappelons les dérapages je crois je
crois qu'on touche à un point enfin
rappelé à plusieurs points importants
le premier c'est ce dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure avec monsieur jour ces
histoires des tabous est ce que jean
marie le pen brise des tabous
moi je crois que les tabous il arrive
après plus tôt c'est au fur et à mesure
que le discours se construit que
j'observe que dans la société française
actuelle on peut de moins en moins dire
les choses il ya par exemple le mot race
aujourd'hui une connotation absolument
péjorative bon mais si vous voyez par
exemple puisque nous aiderons le
centenaire de la guerre 14
la citation de guynemer le héros
aviateurs qui est qui est tombée on dit
le magnifique illustration des vertus de
sa race bon alors moi je moi je
m'intéresse aux mots j'ai aussi été
doyen de faculté où l'on enseignait 27
langues
c'est dire si la linguistique ne vais
pas totalement étrangère
mais ce qui est intéressant ce sont les
choses ce sont les faits comment peut-on
faire grief par exemple à jean marie le
pen de dire quelque chose à propos des
juifs en disant c'est forcément
péjoratif
alors que il dit la même chose de lui
même et des bretons voilà dans le film
bon alors disons les races n'existent
pas certes mais les groupes ethniques
peut-être les peuples peut-être les
nations à vous accueillir
jean marie le pen à cette polémique ça
m'agace surtout pour les gens tant ce
qu'on se focalise sur les noms et pas
sur les réalités parce qu'on peut dire
que les races n'existent pas dans le
professeur jacques a aujourd'hui disparu
bon mais qui disait fièrement à la
télévision les races n'existent pas pour
l'accord écoutez si vous si on met ici
dans cette salle 5 ans devant tout nu et
55 en suédois
eh bien vous saurez même si vous n'êtes
pas professeur d'être
j distinguer les bantous et les suédois
et il essaiera la couleur de son bolide
et que si le congo était peuplée de
victimes se seraient et la suède et la
suède 2 2 ce ne serait pas tout à fait
les mêmes peuples
ce ne serait pas tout à fait les fous
rires mais je vais pas tout à fait les
mêmes sensations serre où il annonce de
jean marie le pen a parlé de race il dit
le groupe
il dit aussi qu' il parle de la race
qu'il va créer
ils n'ont ici non nina m'aligner ligne
et oui la lignée besoin de sens en
glissant la ligne quand on appartient à
ce que l'on croit d'une manière
symbolique et psychologique à une
descendance aligné cette approche c'est
un petit mot race psychologique mais moi
aussi monsieur oui vous allez attendait
les cyril jacquens ben arous et bien en
parler parce que et c'est ce qu'on
déduit aussi de son discours il a une
crainte des autres races entre
guillemets d'un saison où j'ai ressenti
dans vos discussions avec la grâce
français mais on d'autre part ont
peut-être ont peut-être franco à il s'en
est regrettable et aussi la relève je
vais je pense qu'en lui même il y à une
rivalité c'est que logique qui se joue
c'est tout ce sur quoi je vote je
voudrais pas longue à l'émission à ce
débat c'est vous-même mono goni ne se
pare de récemment face à la répétition
du détail mais on n'a pas trouvé de
d'allusions clairement ouvertement
antisémite dans le front national je
pars pas de le pen chez publiable oui
mais ce qu'on oublie c'est que c'est
interdit
on peut se demander ce qu'il reçut que
ce que cela aurait été avant la guerre
évidemment vous direz c'est un faux
procès mais c'est quand même la
nouveauté de l'est
l'interdiction légale alors vous parlez
de vous parler de la ligne et puis on va
avancer dans ce débat parce que vous
souhaitiez pas qu'on focalise sur les
races non les chaumières jour ne
focalisons par amal zellige je crois que
c'est des îles alain politique ce qui
m'a crois que c'est d'aider dévoila et
sur son sombre monsieur albertini sont
les et moi même vous mêmes nous sommes
des héritiers d'une lignée et peut-être
si nous transmettons la vie aux membres
par le mariage
autrement d'ailleurs aux membres de
notre famille nous nous prolongeons
cette ligne voulez-vous que n'ont pas su
aligner des le pen jeu que c'était le
sujet de cette édition jeu oui parce que
vous m'avez présenté comme soutenant
jean marie le pen contre sa fille jeux
jeux soutient jean marie le pen je suis
pas l'adversaire était attendue elle
sera elle sera très heureuse de
l'entendre oui dans le film jean marie
le pen parle de ses filles justement les
enfants je ne crains pas de le dire ont
été persécutés de nombreuses fois par
leur professeur dans l'enseignement
public où elle était mars quelles
étaient les filles de le perdre à part
des réflexions par des piques par des
méchancetés par un climat de l'hostilité
qu'il a exposé du racisme anti le pen si
vous voulez moi ce qui m'a frappé 2004
bertini c'est quand il parle de ses
filles parlent encore de lui absolument
absolument pas tarder à n'existe pas
sans lui ça n'existe pas sans lui
dans quelle mesure est il prêt
d'ailleurs à accepter que ses filles
reprennent ce qu'il a fait en change le
contenu ou la nature de la version us en
hausse dans la question nous a tellement
la question se pose les derniers
événements
en tout cas ça ça pose très fortement la
question il semble en revanche assez
satisfait de retrouver plus dans sa
petite fille que dans sa fille
certains marion maréchal-le pen marion
maréchal-le pen certaines orientations
politiques qui semblent avoir sauté une
génération bien joué pendant que vous
tourner ces images en 87
quel rôle joue marine le pen on la voit
d'élémentaire j'ai un peu lourde
toujours comme ça dans son physique
jeune elle est souvent autour de lui
elle est là un rôle c'était les pommes
déjà non elle est là les sa fille qu'on
voit dans son entourage convoi montre
tout ce que je tenais à dia vous dites
des choses que c'est à dire quand vous
êtes sur un an quand on est sur un
tournage
le savent pas forcément mais on a un
personnage principal et puis on peut
avoir des dialogues à côté avec les
personnages entre guillemets secondaire
ceux qui sont à côté on a vous avez déjà
l'espace
on avait peu de choses à lui dire notre
système était de ne pas lâcher le pen on
voulait pas des intervenants et les avec
sa jeune je suis très jeune 17 ans ce
que je veux dire c'est que le pen vient
de dire pourquoi marine le pen fait
autant de politiques
il vient de dire que la ses filles était
insulté ses filles étaient humiliés au
lycée etc et la marine le pen essaie de
dire voilà on m'insulte pied mais voilà
ce que je suis c'est peut-être son lit
beaucoup marine le pen fait un attentat
contre le domicile de jean marie le pen
à l'époque voilà très jaune à je voulais
finie elle en a gardé le souvenir est
terminée cette idée je crois qu'il n'y a
rien de vraiment transmissibles
sa fille des propres disons non aux
angoisses formatrice de dubert du père
alors donc aller les discours elle peut
tout autrement dit elle est
fondamentalement différente de lui
la france seulement générationnel la
phrase qui est la fin du film dit son
unicité on ne contrôle pas en ce sens
que je ne vous oublie aux ordres de
quiconque
c'est le contraire qui se passe est le
noyau central de jean-marie le pen
cette autonomie majeur est bien à
l'heure actuelle il eut intolérable de
voir que son parti risque de se
dissoudre dans des entre les lits
ressemblance avec des mots des partis
modérés les intérêts le prêt de jean
marie le pen finalement avec ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est de ne plus être
le chef
le pen mais il est bon de ne pas être
chef pardon je vais finir avec la
question c'est de ne plus être le chef
ou bien c'est que sa fille y emmène sa
créature sont partis sur un chemin qu'il
n'a pas voulu pauli est ce que c'est
autrement dit à des accords politiques
écoutez je crois votre commentaire est
un peu biaisé permettez moi d'abord
étonnant mais permettez moi de lui parce
que il explique que ses enfants ont été
persécutés à cause évidemment de son nom
à cause de leur père et vous en tirer la
conclusion qu'il ramène tout à lui bah
oui c'est évident que la persécution de
ses enfants elle tenait à l'existence et
à l'engagement politique de leur père
monsieur albertini avait répondu à ma
question monsieur albertini parler je
réponds non mais je sais pas je prends
personne à partie je réponds à votre
question parce que monsieur albert
pujols a posé aux s'il vous plaît
je crois que jean marie le pen ça ne
vous a pas échappé quand même n'était
pas dans dans sa succession il a pris
plutôt le parti de sa fille marine
plutôt que celle du concurrent que
j'étais huit balles est bon je vous pose
la question de savoir si la rupture
fondamentale n'est pas une rupture de
ligne politique je peins marie le pen
est parti finalement trop à gauche je
pense qu'il craint que marine le pen
c'est sûr ou son entourage non-halal
terre peut-être sur le plan sociétal
économique etc
une partie du combat qui a été le sien
alors je ne ne prend pas parti dans
cette position marine le pen m'a assuré
qu'il n'en était rien bon je pense que
c'est elle qu'il faut poser la question
aux inquiétudes puisque vous lui posez
la question oui oui oui absolument
oui tout à fait c'est parce que le fn
barre à gauche je suis pas passé terme a
résumé un peu trop facile c'est plus
complexe mais c'est plus complexe que
cela ne s'est clairement ce qui est vrai
aussi et ça c'est ce que craint
vraisemblablement marine le pen oui tout
à fait c'est vrai que c'est un homme
qu'on ne contrôle pas et qui considèrent
que président d'honneur du front
national
bon il n'est plus à la barre et qui lui
peut parler à titre personnel et qu'il
ne veut pas aujourd'hui à sondage
raconter le contraire de ce qu'il a dit
précédemment surtout quand les faits
quand même objectivement le monde plutôt
raison surtout quantité de sujets que
vous avez montré ce qu'il y a est ce
qu'il ya dans cette rivalité donc qu'on
perçoit dans ce que vous décrivez comme
politique du moment
est ce qu'il ya une une purge en ce
moment front national est-ce qu'on est
marine le pen est en train de faire le
ménage virer les partisans de son père
autrement dit c'est assez compliqué à
dire il ya une série d'événements qu'il
est dur d'interpréter deux manières
univoque monsieur gollnisch madame
arnautu qui est elle aussi une proche de
jean-marie le pen ont tous les deux été
sortis de deux commissions internes au
front national des commissions
importantes mais il n'ya pas que
d'autres sont rentrés hier et st hub
rendre récemment eu beaucoup de
changements dans les secrétaires
départementaux du front national qui
sont des sortes de préfets qui
représente le parti dans les différents
départements
beaucoup de gens présents depuis
longtemps dans le fn sont partis
beaucoup ont été remplacées par de
jeunes gens à marine lui récemment dit
mariniste
philippe autistes ide en tout cas voilà
voilà j'en arrive 1-2 récemment
peut-être avec un panachage un peu plus
large en matière de d'options politiques
donc on peut voir dans ces mouvements
effectivement sinon une purge mais en
tout cas le symptôme d'un parti qui est
vraiment en train de changer à vitesse
grand v
alors évidemment s'adapter pour sa dette
il ya nouvelle bonne à une nouvelle
stratégie un nouveau discours il est
facile quand on est du côté de ceux qui
sont sortants d'ivoire une purge
effectivement la purge réel de marine le
pen c'est la purge de son père son père
ont dit qu'ils voulaient pas le pouvoir
c'est pas vrai et veut le pouvoir mais
son père son élément de gloire est quand
même d'avoir recréer cette extrême
droite est puissante en france assez
unifiée malgré tout malgré tout ce qu'on
peut dire
et qu'est ce que va faire marine le pen
sans ce personnage ce personnage qui est
beaucoup d'intuition ce personnage dont
la violence verbale dans le dans le dos
il ya un certain génie lorsque sa fille
séparer de lui
elle lui dit il dit qu'elle me rende mon
nom c'est assez prodigieux jeudi elle
épouse leurs compagnons dis donc
louis aliot qui ne supporte pas c'est la
disparition de ce noyau qu'il y ait et
qu'il a recréé c'est ça
c'est cet enjeu malheureusement myard il
ya quand même l'âge qu'ils jouent mais
ya sept
cette fondation d'une ligne et je
voulais parler on en a parlé là tout à
l'heure qui s'achèverait et puis l'ont
eue en lors de petites de président
devant et le sentiment qu'on sent dans
votre film chez jean marie le pen d'il
ya trente ans encore une fois il a pas
bougé acquis qu'il a réussi des choses
qui ne veut pas qu'on lui enlève cette
réussite et c'est étonnant notamment des
juges et finir on le voit notamment dans
cet extrait où il parle de sa réussite
financière
regardez juste peu de médecins et une
salle de réception
quand je sois du monde des amis mais je
suis arrivé ici là tissu des murs et l
époque il a est à dire qu'il avait plus
de 5 820 en voilà payet à lille
célibataire puisqu'il ya une rafale de
dossiers sur la moitié de mon lit voilà
il ya évidemment une vue superbe sur
paris magnifique
il y avait vent un peu gâté par ses
bâtiments modernes
on voudrait savoir quel est le montant
exact de votre fortune sur la personne
c'est à dire personne sa main sur sa
main et une affaire privée détruit
quelque est ce que vous appelez
quelqu'un de riche non je crois que je
suis pas très riche c'est étonnant bruno
gollnisch parce que finalement le
dernier tabou de jean marie le pen c'est
l'argent il avait ce pas de dire qu'il
est riche elle il est riche c'est le
talent de l'argent français
écoutez le chacun sait qu'il a hérité de
la fortune d'un ami mort célibataire
héritiers des servants n'était pas le
seul à insulter bon un héritier lambert
qui
avait une grande admiration pour son
combat qui avaient été prouvés le fait
que le domicile de jean marie le pen
avait été plastiqué à l'époque un tout
l'immeuble c'était je me rate à l'heure
où il était en quelque sorte à la rue et
qui lui a c'est vrai étant malade lui a
légué ses biens
je vous signale que le premier héritier
des ciments lambert ça a été l'état qui
a pris 70% de de droits de succession au
passage je me souviens c'était assez
émouvant
le jour où qui a été un grand jour dans
la percée du front national où jean
marie le pen se fêtent la victoire qui a
vu l'entrée de 11 députés européens en
1984 c'était la première percée du front
national à l'époque je ne risquait pas
de devenir député j'avais pris la
dernière place sur la liste et il ne
fait une grande soirée pour fait pour
fêter ça il ya 200 300 personnes il ya
une très chaude ambiance et vers minuit
il interrompt tout et il demande une
minute de silence pour celui dont nous
sommes les hôtes à savoir lambert qui
lui avait légué cette maison je trouvais
c'était un as et un assez beau geste
je pense quand même qu'il se reconnaît
héritiers voilà il n'ya pas du tout de
racisme chez le mineur il a dit qu il a
de l'intérêt pour les autres peuples
pour les autres rares si vous deviez
revenir je vous signale c'était pas ma
question et non non mais c'est un homme
s'est en revanche ce qui est vrai c'est
que c'est un homme qui se reconnaît
héritier et rien qui vous fait partie
d'une lignée
bon il se trouve qu'il est celle il
croit à l'existence d'un peuple français
qui n'est pas réductible à d'autres
peuples
exactement comme charles de gaulle le
disait alain peyrefitte
si vous voyez les ce que disait charles
de gaulle je suis pas sûr d'ailleurs que
jean marie le pen serait allé aussi loin
cécile alduy c'est intéressant parce que
dans le film de pierre jouve de la même
manière jean marie le pen se revendique
pratiquement hérité des droïdes il parle
des celtes effectivement et de la force
de l'image chez les celtes la capacité à
transmettre de l'image
est-ce qu'il l'a transmis à sa fille est
ce que marine le pen là ça un peu moins
un peu moins notamment parce que elle a
beaucoup modérer son discours
et alors elle arrêtait la grande geste
nationale pour les grands discours du
1er mai donc là le dernier 1er mai
c'était un discours qui aurait pu être
signé par jean marie le pen du point de
vue du récit de jeanne d'arc eux qui
résiste à l'invasion des anglais la
trahison des élites et cédera donc est
un sous le nom de motifs qui reviennent
toujours et donc qui sont répétés et là
elle est dans la lignée mais sinon sur
les plateaux de télévision n'est pas
complètement différemment l1 qu'un
discours assez quotidien concrets qui
parle aux gens fait pas un tribun
autrement dit comme son père l'était
dans le charisme qu'elle a sur scène la
manière dont elle a quel à de
communiquer avec ses militants
mais jean marie le pen a le goût de
l'image il a une culture littéraire très
différente de celle de la marine le pen
ben le pen fille des fiches et travaille
elle potasse c'est ces sujets mais elle
a un côté elle veut vraiment montrer
qu'elle est compétente sur un saut
nombre de sujets dont elle peut être
très technique sans être justement du
côté de l'image
new delhi joie du petit lait en chantant
mais je crois je crois que marine le pen
a de très grande qualité y compris
d'orateur et mais que jean marie le pen
savait aussi parlé des problèmes
quotidiens des gens mais sur la question
de la culture dont vous parliez jean
marie le pen me fais une confidence et
ce qui est d'actualité au moment où l'on
parle de la réforme des collèges il
s'est trouvé élèves après au final guère
chez les chez les jésuites à vannes
il me dit on c'était la guerre on avait
faim il faisait froid etc
chaque trimestre on apprenait 400 verts
français il m'a 200 et relate un sens
vers grecque
il est certain et à partir de la classe
de seconde
tous les deux mois ont passé le
baccalauréat dans les conditions de
l'épreuve quatre heures de dissertation
ou l'oral qui fait que quand on arrivait
au bac on avait déjà passé dix fois
jamais
jamais le pen à singer qui que ce soit
non il a son style ce que je retrouve
chez chez marine le pen c'est soit elle
singe son père alors ces jeunes dames
c'est l'invention de son père qui
d'ailleurs s'attache à une héroïne sans
sexe il a les deux prénoms jeanne et
marie chez lui et ses soins donc elle
colle au discours de son père au
cérémonial de son père soit elle singe
carrément les congrès de la droite
locale à tort le vocabulaire est
communicant le vocabulaire
jamais on n'aurait pu approcher à tous
les maires tout le vocabulaire politique
aujourd'hui on arrêtait du sceau de la
civilisation elle est dans son autre
sens
elle est un peu une collaboratrice à la
fin du c'est ce que je déduis s'est elle
n'a pas d'originalité verbal est ce que
la provocation genre hilali c'est normal
c'est mal vu dans notre société sps que
l'art de la provocation de jean marie le
pen peut manquer au front national qu'en
pensez-vous donné qu'il ya quelque chose
qui va dépasser
on ne sait pas quoi il ya quelque chose
de l'ordre du délire quand on transmet d
anxiété des angoisses à longueur de
discours on s'adresse à des gens qui
sont dans l'insécurité qui ont des
l'appétence pour le français souvent des
gens qui sentent plus de repères qui il
ya l'europe c'est déjà le cas pour jean
marie le pen oui mais jean marie le pen
a quelque chose de genuine en lui
c'est à dire dans ce discours y ait
quelque chose chez lui où il ya eu la
disparition a été personnel c'est ce qui
se transmettent personnel et lorsqu ils
transgressent c'est extrêmement
personnel il apprend aux gens à
transgresser justement le rétablissement
du vocabulaire alors le mic albertini
sur la provocation
est-ce que la provocation peut manquer
au front national version marine le pen
jean-marie le pen pense que le fn a
progressé grâce à ces provocations
marine le pen pense que le fait là
progressé en dépit on dit en regrettant
que la sarkozie en coulisse dit elle a
fait une erreur de virey son père parce
que cette provocation va lui manquer il
ya une partie de l'électorat qui en a
besoin mais je pense que le seul moyen
de répondre à la question c'est de juger
l'un et l'autre sur leurs résultats
respectifs pour marine le pen en manque
encore un peu de recul même si elle a
fait à la dernière présidentielle
le meilleur score de l'histoire du parti
je pense qu'on aura des éléments plus
solide pour y répondre en 2017
non mes éléments c'est le vent qui
souffle ci aura psy à padoue êtes sûr
l'allégorie de la planche à voile télé
vous attendez le vent qui sauf le vent a
soufflé si souffle romain dumas et il
suffit que le vent souffle logis il
suffit que le vent selon non mais il
faut savoir le pardon est forte
oui est ce que jean marie le pen voulait
le pouvoir c'est une question qui
revient souvent vous dit bruno gollnisch
oui oui définitivement et d'autres en
août et monsieur jour qui a beaucoup
pratiqué gens à l'open pour préparer il
ya 30 ans il est vrai une trentaine
d'années ce documentaire en atteste et
je trouve ça intéressant parce que vos
confrères vont répétant qu'il ne voulait
pas le pouvoir et l chocquois le pen dit
très justement comme si on me l'avait
présentée sur un plat d'argent
bon quand on voit ce qu'a été par
exemple entre deux tours de la campagne
de 2002 où toutes les règles les
constitutionnelles légales du csa ont
été violées foulé aux pieds on a mis une
partie de la france dans la rue contre
le résultat d'une élection parfaitement
légal normal et pacifique
on peut se dire que effectivement on lui
a mis beaucoup de bâtons dans les roues
mais moi aussi je voudrais en placer une
le dol dans le documentaire jean marie
le pen dit le fn est un calmant c'est un
régulateur a nommé ce qui autrement dit
laissez-moi une place je ne vous
prendrai pas nous essentiel non j'aurais
cela veut dire non c'est pas ça ça veut
dire ça veut dire que et là je rejoins
ce que disait monsieur monsieur jour il
y a des gens qui souffrent en france
parce que monsieur joual j'ai
l'impression dit que le discours de jean
marie le pen est volontairement pyogenes
c'est c'est la thèse à vis du l épave
lanceur il est nature il surf sur les
peurs et ses amis à côté c'est que ces
craintes existent elles sont légitimes
est ce que est ce que
oui ou non nous vivons quand même une
période d'un problème où l'islamisme est
une réalité le mend souhait est un
problème où la désindustrialisation
notre pays est un problème l'expo
l'explosion du chômage etc
ce sont des problèmes que j'en avais le
pen et lui seul lui seul a vu à vue
c'est un petit peu un décalage entre ce
qui m'intéresse c'est la question de la
provocation
alors la question de la volonté de
prendre le pouvoir ou pas alors je pense
que personne peut être dans la tête de
jean marie le pen par rapport à la
question du poids de toute façon il est
parti comme avec un parti qui en 1972
faisait 0,78 pour cent des voix donc la
marge de progression était immense est
arrivé à 18% et à au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle et est en
lui-même un succès électoral non
négligeable donc je pense que cette
question de prendre le pouvoir ou pas ne
se pose pas parce qu'elle laissait
jamais posé de façon concrète personnes
en 2002 s'est dit demain c'est jean
marie le pen qui sera président de la
république
donc c'est une question un petit peu
arbitraire ce qu'il me semblait le
premier tour dans d'établissement je
pense qu'il ya eu un trappeur wake up
call un sursaut en disant tiens c'est
pas genre jospin et chirac au deuxième
tour donc il ya eu une mobilisation très
intense ça c'est évident mais la
question qui est plus important c'est
comment on parvient au pouvoir et c'est
vrai que jean marie le pen avait cette
idée que c'est la provocation qui a
assuré un espace médiatique vers
nationale une caisse de résonance et il
a toujours dit ce qui importe en
politique c'est de durer il l'a fait et
marine le pen est pas elle seule louis
aliot bono maigret à l'époque d'autres
tours dale ont dit non au contraire un
moment donné si on veut passer la barre
de la majorité au moins absolu absolue
ou bien assez proche de celle là il faut
tout de même élargir l'électorat et les
provocations rebute une certaine partie
les lecteurs ya très longtemps que le fn
est fissurée entre stratégie exactement
et je pense qu'on peut expliquer les
différences de discours de deux prises
de paroles d'utilisation des mots donc
le fait qu'elle n'utilise pas le mot
race et que son père le fait par ces
deux stratégies différentes mais comme
vous l'avez dit au début de l'émission
marine le pen vient de vous rassurer
indien qui avait pas de changement de
ligne donc je pense que ce qu'il faut
faire pour les électeurs c'est de voir
vraiment le
qu'est-ce-qui sur coise qu'on juge les
parties à cesser le programme est donc
qu'est-ce qui va être appliqué quand on
les met au pouvoir ou bien la
communication politique qui fait
pourquoi on va donc à la marine et à le
programme politique et le programme
politique a peu changé par rapport au
temps de jean marc il sait ce que c'est
ce que vous dites déjà au boulot
gollnisch est votre inquiétude vous
l'avez manifester auprès de marine le
pen vous l'avais dit c'était ce serait
qu'il ait changé
elle vous a dit non vous vouliez
rebondir là dessus le pen n'a jamais eu
aucun conseiller il avait pas deux il
avait des amis oui gens comme ça en
coquin mais s'il n'avait pas mis l'ipo
non mais un filippo qui d'ailleurs je
bull regardais je situe toujours dans
jeu politique et finalement vous avez
une formidable tendresse pour jean marie
le pen nous mais je vois son je vois
sans son unicité si on peut dire mais
monsieur jours jean-marie le pen avait
beaucoup de conseillers nguyen fasse
enfin il n'est est tributaire d'aucuns
en particulier ça c'est certain mais il
prenait beaucoup d'avis il s'entourait
d'avis et je me souviens de discussion
du bureau exécutif du front national
gestion 7,8
nous avions sous quelques fois des avis
divers divergent quelque fois les avis
convergent il écoutait et il y avait des
personnalités très diverses et venant
d'horizons assez assez varié ce qu'on
faisait je crois la richesse sur la
provocation a légué c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça n'est ce pas jean marie
le mort est une petite minute lui jean
marie le pen n'a jamais cultivé la
provocation pour la provocation mais il
a considéré que le discours dominant de
toute façon le diabolise ray et que s'il
fallait accepter cette diabolisation
pour laisser libre dans son propos et
bien tant pis voilà c'est ça la grande
différence
moi même je ne suis pas hostile à la
dédiabolisation j'ai toujours considéré
la diabolisation comme injuste le
problème c'est jusqu'où est-on prêt à
aller pour être dédiaboliser l'époque on
aseptise le front national je traduis
vous n'emploiera jouer les éléments
diabolisation est une arme psychologie
comme à nos adversaires juste que marine
le pen est elle prête à aller pour
arriver au pouvoir
manifestement jusqu'à
retiré à son père à la présidence
d'honneur du parti peut-être l'exclure
on verra dans l'est dans les prochains
mois peut-être encore plus tard changer
le nom du parti
ce qu'il en est des lignes changer de
ligne c'est se rapprocher de la droite
traditionnelle tout dépend de ce qu'on
appelle changer de ligne changer les
fondamentaux du parti
je pense à la préférence nationale
cécile alduy a rappelé que ce n'est pas
le cas en revanche introduire de
nouvelles thématiques un nouveau
traitement de certains sujets modifier
radicalement le centre de gravité du
discours frontiste
ça s'est déjà fait ou fait en train
d'être faire du social voulait dire par
exemple le régalien aussi en résumé
merci à tous les cadres d'avoir été sur
ce plateau pour débattre librement les
pu le remarquer bruno gollnisch pour y
continuer évidemment alimenter ce débat
sur les réseaux sociaux hashtag docu
débat où il ya le mail de l'émission le
courriel de l'émission qui s'affiche en
bas de votre écran
la semaine prochaine claire barsacq
barsacq s'intéressera aux abeilles qui
ont en commun avec le front national
d'être elle aussi gouverné par une reine
à très vite sur public sénat
bon
plus qu'une